دائما ما كان للفن والادب رساله ساميه وفي
سوريا كان يجب ان تظهر هذه الرساله في
الوقت العصيب اي بعد الزلزال المدمر
فنانون ومثقفون من سوريا كانوا على الموعد
بعضهم باع لوحاته لاجل التبرع بثمنها
للمنكوبين واخرون استغنوا عن ريع كتبهم
لاجل دعم ضحايا الزلزال نجوم دراما ايضا
كانوا داعمين لمن دمر الزلزال حياتهم باسم
يخر فادي صبيح شكرا مرتجى روعه السعدي
وغيرهم على الارض داخل سوريا مكسيم خليل
تيم حسن سامر المصري وكثيرون خارج سوريا
تطوعوا وساهموا في التبرع للمتضررين
الكثير من الفنانين قدموا المعونه ماديه
كانتا عينيه او حتى تضامنيا مع ضحايا
الزلزال يكون الفن حاضرا في معركه
السوريين القاسيه ضد الماساه الاخيره
[موسيقى]
من دمشق الممثل رامي احمر رامي يسعد صباحك
اهلا بك معنا نورنا في صباح العربيه كان
هناك اطلاق نداءات عاجله لاغاثه منكوبي
زلزال تركيا انتم شخصيا كيف تعطيتم مع هذه
النداءات
صباح الخير يسعد
صباحك
[موسيقى]
كتير كانت
ان شاء الله اخواتك موجودين بالمراكز
بيرجعوا على بيوتهم
يعني بصراحه هي نوع من كوارث
طبيعيه الصعبه جدا بعتقد انه
زلزال تحديدا
ممكن العاصفه انه في
ممكن اي كارثه ثانيه لكن الزلزال تحديدا
نحن معنا
يعني بين الانسان يكون ناجي او يكون مضطر
يكون الصوت اوضح شوي بيتقطع الصوت وهذا
مفهوم بس انت لحظه وقوع الزلزال هل في
اشخاص دغري تواصلت معهم اقارب اصحاب شو
كانت رده فعلك او المصاري زلزال انا اهلي
موجودين محافظه حلب بالاساس من اهلي عم
تسمعوني منيح هلا سامعين
احسن تمام
اقاربي واهلي هم موجودين بمحافظه ساعه
وقوع الزلزال يعني نحن موجودين بمحافظه
دمشق ونحن بنعرف انه محافظة دمشق تبعد شوي
عن محافظه حلب وحسن
بهلعه كبير
دغري تواصلنا كل الاشخاص اللي نحن بنعرفهم
بمحافظه ادب حقيقه حجم الخراب والدمار
كثير كبير
حاولنا من الساعات الاولى انه نحنا نعمل
اي مساعده بس لحتى
اهالينا ننقذهم اهالينا هن الموجودين
بمحافظه حلب وباللاذقيه وبحما عده محافظات
هي للاسف تم اعلانها منكوبه عم نحاول
نساعدهم باكثر شيء نحن ممكن نقدم فيه
لوحاتهم في فنانين استغنوا عن كتاباتهم
بالنسبه لنجوم الدراما كيف يعني اغاثه
ضحايا الزلزال
[موسيقى]
من مناطق انطلاق البولمان لمناطق وصوله
لحتى نحن نامن لهم مسكن ونامل لهم
قريبه اذا لم يساعد يعني كانه عم نشوف مين
عم بزاود على مين وصار دائما توجيه
اتهامات
لحجم المساعده ومين اكثر ومين كانه صار
سباق ومنافسه لماذا
يعني
للاسف هذا هذا الكلام محزن لا هو ممكن
دائما السوشيال ميديا هي بتبرد هاي القصص
بحجم اضخم من ما هي عليه احنا لسنا بصدد
ان نحكم على شخص او نحكم على فرق
بصدد انه نحن نحاول نضل عم نساعد العالم
لانه احنا موضوعنا موضوعنا ليس يوم ويوم
اسبوع موضوعنا نحن يعني
[موسيقى]
بنساعد ليش نحن الفنانين مولايين لانه
بالاساس يعني مهلتنا هي
تصب في مكان انساني دائما عنا رساله نحن
لازم نوصلها
نحن ممكن نساعد فيها ونوصلها لباقي الدول
احنا بنشكرك جزيل الشكر على وجودك وظهورك
معنا شكرا جزيلا لكم ويعطيكم الف عافيه
وموفقين من دمشق الممثل رامي احمر شكرا لك